he pushed man on the train track the
yeah the yell on the train track
affair with the yeah and then she said
i'm gonna take you down man just pushed
her in front of a train
and got on with his day i'm done
[Music]
um someone messaged oh crikey
someone messaged us a while ago and was
like
um you got we need to pick a name for
our fans
i reckon when we get to 10k youtube subs
yeah that's like a
this is cool let's start naming these
hoes okay
what what we have you got any ideas i
don't know
like the giggle guzzlers giggle
guzzlers
sng slop and toppers i don't know you
guys let us know
yeah that's a good point actually you
guys think of fan names for yourselves
in the comments or whatever send us
messages and then we'll move from there
we'll go from there i don't want to do
something corny like
sng nation oh god no nation ones are so
dead no no no no no it needs to be so
cool
so yeah um as always guys
patreon where you at merch where you at
um new designs coming soon hope you guys
are excited for november two episodes a
week
should be dope um and yeah i'm ready to
boogie gee
yeah mom you got it funny uh yeah do you
know
where and or how the middle finger
gesture originated
no but that's so funny because whose
story was it on the other day
was it jay's was a meme and someone was
like
someone put one day someone must have
put their middle of the finger up and
thought
this is offensive offensive to someone
yeah i saw that in a tweet i think
but yeah no go on i think i think there
are two there are two um
theories or whatever it's called two
origin stories the first one is
it's like ancient greek times so the
middle finger represented a dick
like when you showed it a middle finger
representing the dick and the two
things on the other side represented the
balls so it was like a it was like a
it was a gesture so it was one from a
man
to a woman to a woman yeah i'm gonna
[ __ ] you
but there's a gang i know there's a
there's another theory that enough i
think it was like a french war between
france and england
english uh soldiers used used to use
bourbon arrows
and they were bone men so obviously you
know some people do this and some people
do this
yes so the people that used to do this
back in the day
this is the same two things they used to
use to so i'm gonna shoot you guys
no no no let me finish oh sorry
i thought this i'm gonna shoot you
because obviously that's what that means
so these are the two things that
the english bowman used to use to dup
you off the french man
yeah um but if the english men got
caught
they would slice off these fingers so
they can't they couldn't use the bow and
arrow anymore oh
but when the english man darpied a
frenchman and got away with it they
would throw up this side
saying so that's those are the two
phrases of the origination of the
the middle finger that's gang let's do
it that's gang but yeah read up on it if
you want to read up
well google it rather if you want to
read up more about what i just said
about the middle finger origination
that's very cool yeah man live all right
cool man um i've got a fan request
yeah always let's go so
i wear it there i actually screenshotted
this one to stop
me trying to scroll and stuff scrolling
and all this [ __ ] ain't gonna score for
your pictures no no no
i screenshot it today oh go go go go um
prepping that
so this yarl thing broth
what y'all opinion on the new generation
love scene y'all oh why they love to
this is a good one actually so what's
your opinion
on the new generations love scene yeah
or why they love toxic relationships
so yeah what's your opinion i'm i'm into
so what's your opinion on the new
generations love scene love scene
and why do you think the new generation
love a toxic relationship
when they say new generation didn't mean
like younger than us
like millennial generation i'm assuming
um
i'm assuming she must be older then i
guess maybe
and i think i think the obvious answer
is technology
um because i think we've said this on a
pod before
uh well i've definitely said this on the
pod before if again i'm assuming she's
older so i'm assuming she's like a
proper parent like she's got kids in
like teens or twenties
so my assumption is when she was growing
up obviously there was no technology
without technology like we i think we
discussed this you have to talk to
everyone
right within your neighboring miles or
whatever yeah yeah
yeah yeah whereas now you've got apps
you've got instagram you've got twitter
you've got
it tonight you've got everything so you
can be branching out and meeting people
here there and everywhere and it's
easier to pattern a ting
if it's just a b if it's a potential
relationship and obviously things could
get toxic because of social media
a lot of people don't like the fact that
guys like women's pictures on instagram
yeah people don't like the fact that
there's a stereotype between like
girls buying girls being bought stuff
from guys like there's so much there's
so much that's going on
right now in this day and age millennial
wise anyway
um and that's all social media in my
opinion that's social media
yeah um i don't think
toxicity necessarily is
is the word yes there are some shitty
relationships but
i don't know i don't know let me know
what you think i might have might have
to double back
mine's like a little bit um on the top
on the toxic side um this thing's not
playing ball today
on the toxic side i reckon it literally
boils down to
probably because yeah like
people are so so let me put this in
context so
um there's a movie going around at the
minute i never it's the social dilemma
yeah i've seen the trailer i haven't
seen the movie but i've heard from
all different places about it right the
trailers just talking together yeah
okay so it just talks about obviously
like
people's obsession with social media and
all this stuff and how it
shows you what you want to see and shows
you what you will make you angry on
purpose so you keep reading it and all
this stuff so
and it was the one of the guys i was
actually watching on another podcast and
it was talking about how bad it is for
people and all this stuff and the guy
made a point that
he was like agreed people are addicted
to their phones and stuff like that but
like
that's not social media's fault that
we're addicted to social media
it's our fault that we're addicted to
social media and
the reason we'd allow ourselves or have
the ability to be addicted social media
and our phones and [ __ ] like that is
because we're just we've just got so
much
more time yeah than we ever had
yeah in the past okay so like
people are just bored yeah like back in
the day when you had to when there was
no
supermarket deliveries yeah and you're
walking to supermarket you're having to
do shopping you're walking all the way
home
like not as many people had cars like
um yeah like people were doing a lot
more manual labor jobs and all this
stuff
people didn't have time to be sitting on
their phones all day true they didn't
obviously we didn't have the technology
anyway but we wouldn't have had the time
to do that
if we wanted to true but now i can order
everything
from my phone if i wanted to yeah i
don't have to go anywhere i don't need
to go
i've been working from home for the last
six months i don't even need to go to
work anymore i've got so much extra time
yeah that can just sit on my phone
yeah i mean yeah um like i don't need to
be doing diy around my yard
like i'm i'm fine i can just
do [ __ ] and anything i want to read
i can just put a podcast on or i can put
audio book and i listen to it in the car
i don't ever have to
take your time out take much more time
out of you yeah i've got more time in
the day to be spending on social media
so i spend it that
cause in the truth is when i'm busy yeah
i'm not on social media true true truth
um and the way i see it is is like with
the talks to bring it back to the
toxicity thing i think it's a case of
the new generation again
they're growing up with all this time on
their hands yeah they have
energy to be caring about like you said
your man liking other girls pictures and
stuff like that you have energy for that
because like
back in the day especially as well like
women weren't working
yeah women weren't working so they would
look to a man to provide everything for
them okay
so if you're looking for a man to
provide everything
you're more likely when he's doing back
in the day now it's liking girls
pictures back in the day would catch a
man looking
at like a girl's arse or something this
is a little bit like a little rubber
neck
you're more likely to brush that off you
might give him like a slap on the arm
yeah and you'll brush it off because
there's more important things in your
life it's not worth causing a drama
about
these days especially young generation
where they don't they don't need them
out of anything yeah like women get
their own money
women do their own [ __ ] and especially
if we're talking teenagers
they're not even needing to do that yeah
they're chilling in their parents [ __ ]
on their parents
they've got time and there's also
another thing as well i just think
people growing up now
just love drama a little bit more oh god
yes like i said they've got nothing to
worry about
nothing there's nothing concerned they
ain't got bills to pay there's like
there's nothing to be worried about
nowadays that you can just
relish in drama yeah and like
people just love toxic [ __ ]
speaking of what you are speaking of i
remember seeing a video of
it wasn't a podcast it was like maybe
like black chat like remember that back
chat thing
that was on like youtube and twitter it
was like what's that
it was like four guys and four girls i
think so yeah yeah yeah
i don't know if it was that but there
was something going on to it uh a few
years ago maybe a few months ago i
remember yeah and they were talking
about relationships and toxicity
yeah and one of the girls said sometimes
you just need to start fake arguments
for a bit of drama
not with me you don't you know what i
mean like and obviously demand them or
like what you want about but the girls
agreed yeah
they're like yeah i'm like no no no
i don't need drama that's the thing as
well this is like this is a v
this is such a glancing overview yeah
but it's just like in my experience yeah
women actually do
enjoy a bit of drama and men just want
to be chilled
just all the time all just want to be
children i just want to be chilled
i don't want drama i don't want us to
argue about anything yeah
ever yeah i don't want to have one
argument yeah and people actually
like i've spoken to women where they're
like but do you not think there's
something wrong in your relationship if
you're not arguing
i've i've heard that's not being asked
to me but i've heard that happen before
do you not think there's something wrong
if you and your partner are not arguing
listen to the words that are coming out
of your mouth if me
and the woman i love don't beef then
there's something
wrong that doesn't make sense
i can understand maybe an aspect of why
they asked that question
yeah my i'm just thinking out of the box
here yeah i'm thinking
maybe the reason why they think that is
because
no one either party's not being 100
truthful
does that make sense so either party
isn't being 100 themselves not even me
so they're just being like agreeable
agreeable
yeah yeah yeah yeah just so just to an
avoidance yeah yeah yeah so
maybe that could be that makes sense but
the thing is yeah for me it's just like
sometimes i
also feel like that's important to be
agreeable sometimes it's not necessarily
that you're like a doormat
yeah i've been uh obviously there's bad
times i've had situations
where um my girlfriend might be
annoyed about something and i make a
choice in my head or i might be annoyed
about
something and i may make a choice in my
head is like
what do i want more to beat her about
this specific thing
or enjoy the rest of my evening yeah and
if i want to beef her more than i want
to enjoy my evening then we'll beef
yeah and if i want to enjoy my evening
more than i want to beef you let it
slide let it slide or not even just
about enjoy my evening whether hurting
her feelings like if i want to bring up
her not washing the [ __ ] dishes or
whatever
do i want to hurt her feelings or not
her feelings or just like ruin her mood
yeah
more then i want her to have a good
evening yeah and most of the time i'm
just like
cool i'll rather just enjoy the evening
or let her enjoy the evening yeah i know
you mean and then obviously there's
gonna be other occasions where you're
like enough is enough
yeah like less beef because right now i
want to get this off my chest more than
i want you to enjoy your evening yeah
and then that's when we'll have a bit of
drama
but i'm not just going to start beefing
over everything because it's healthy to
have arguments in your relationship
oh and i agree with you don't worry
completely but yeah i'm not
necessarily i think there's a heap of
reasons why people love toxic
relationships but i was actually
speaking to
someone a few months ago um
and there was a girl and she was telling
me about her relationship and stuff like
that
okay and she openly told me like she
likes
toxic [ __ ] she's attracted to toxic
[ __ ] do i know this gum no okay she's
attracted to
toxic [ __ ] okay and i was like
i mean okay but what's wrong with you
why why
why why do you know like happiness like
that's what that's what leads me to
believe in just like oh so you're bored
is what you're saying
on a day to day you must be bored
because if you've got hobbies
you haven't got time to be beefing with
your partner yeah if you if you're into
origami because
you ain't got time to be beefing with
people because you want to do origami
yeah like that's the thing that in my
head i just think oh anytime someone
says
i just think you're bored you're
bored and the same with like um a lot of
people
this is guys and girls but they're like
they need attention
they need attention they're just i just
want some attention i always see stories
that i just need attention
and they're like oh that's all cute and
stuff like that but what i'm hearing is
you're bored
get a hobby find some [ __ ] it's cool
[ __ ] to do
because granted i'll give you attention
when the campus it's like
use your life because um so yeah i think
that's why people like toxic [ __ ] i hear
that
i don't know man it's i hate toxic [ __ ]
oh i
don't think any right human loves it
it's weird
it's weird it's very weird i don't know
so you stay wrong though like at the end
of the day
everyone has free will and they can do
what they want yeah
i'm not judging i don't know i said
that's the next thing yeah i'm not
judging
just do what the [ __ ] you want to do
thank you [ __ ] it's the next thing
but anyway i hope that answers her
question
that's how it does sometimes i feel
people
think that we're going to have the
answer yeah and then we just go around
circles for 10 minutes
and then we forget what the question
even was and then i'll tell you about
the question
and then we get so off topic and then
we're like so yeah
thanks for the question
[Laughter]
but yeah man just jokes oh i [ __ ]
know sorry guys
what did i ask that i have
are you gonna
i'm going to try and stick it to like
once a day if yeah
cool man i've got cool i've got a fun
question to ask you and a more serious
question to ask you
i'll go with the more serious one why
not okay i like serious questions
it's a kind of fun but not okay what
so obviously you're a nigerian yeah in
african culture
yeah what other type of african
do nigerians hate the most
i would i wouldn't necessarily say they
hate them but i think there's
more of a rivalry are you gonna say
ghana yeah
why is that i don't know that's the
thing i think i honestly don't know
because when i think of africa
i always think nigerian god i always do
and i don't know why and there's maybe
yeah i generally don't have the answer
but i think it's one of them ones where
if if you grew up a united fan you're
automatically going to hate c
yeah do you know what i mean i know what
you mean it's like a darby thing that's
weird though but why is it i don't have
the answer
is that in africa as well or is it just
in england again i don't know
because when i schooled in nigeria i
didn't even know there was this kind of
nigerian garden or you know i mean just
fighting for like top spot i never knew
that yeah it was only until
probably uni when afrobeats started
hitting a bit more
all those kind of things that's probably
when and like the jollof rice war who
does the best jollof rice
that was it was uni times that made me
realize oh there's a little
there's a little battle between yeah
yeah um who's top and who's not but but
when i lived there and when i schooled
there
it there was nothing in my in my eyes
anyway there was no such thing as that
wow so i don't i don't have the honest
answer for that yeah i don't know i
don't know
i would have said probably ghana than if
if i assumed you were going to say
yeah it might be that yeah that's the
only one i could think because like i
spoken to
a girl i think i taught this story
before like well there's a girl she's
from ghana yeah that i used to work with
yeah yeah yeah
and then like when i asked her like how
were you
nigerian or something i think that's
i'll after you nigerian
and she got so offended and she was like
now from ghana i was like
okay i can see why you're getting
offended the funny thing about that is a
lot of people think
obviously you know me so you know i'm
not from ghana but a lot of people that
meet me for the first time that are
african
that that can distinguish between two
think i'm ghanaian how do you
distinguish i don't know
i don't know that's the thing i don't
know like people say i look ghanian how
the [ __ ] does a ghanaian look yeah
yeah but i'm not like i'm not guardian a
lot of people think i'm ghanaian
i don't know why it just i don't yeah
you know i mean do you guys have similar
cultures and [ __ ]
because i asked her i remember there was
a name i think i told the story before
there's a name
the name and she it was a nigerian name
yeah and she could i asked her do you
know how to pronounce it
and she was like why are you asking me
like that's a nigerian name
i'm not nigerian and i was like cool so
can you pronounce it
and then she was like yeah it's this and
i was like cool
um i want to say the culture similar um
again i don't i've never been to ghana
so i can't really relate
but can you distinguish between like
like like how she knew that was a
nigerian oh yeah i can
it's the same way you can probably
distinguish a
i don't know english name to an irish
name you may not need to be fair you can
you can just you know
you're right you can disconnect yeah so
it's exactly the same it's just
completely different continent it's
exactly the same thing that's fair
enough yeah
interesting because i was watching um
listen to uh
everything i say is from another podcast
before i say i need to do more one more
time
[Laughter]
there's a chinese giant wow racist
there's a korean comedian
but he's not really curious he just made
a mistake yeah not true he's
his name's bobby lee you've seen it yeah
so he's american
oh nettie are you is he on that he
doesn't there's a
anyway continue would you say commit
stand-up communities now there's a
chinese-style comedian
called um on netflix at the minute
called
it was a suit yeah yeah if you if you've
seen it i've seen something i didn't see
the whole thing
[ __ ] hilarious i've seen it twice oh
really he's really good
really good um ronnie chang his name is
whatever um ronnie chang is his name but
anyway bobby lee
yeah he's um korean
okay and he says like his dad used to
rank asians okay
no he used to rank races so he said his
korean dad used to sit down
and rank races okay so he would be like
the most powerful races in the world
and he would always be like koreans
then um he would be like koreans
then white people yeah
then like something like i don't even
know
vietnamese people yeah and it would be
second to last would be black people
yeah and then last would be chinese
people
and then apparently in korea they hate
chinese people why they just do
i don't know they think like they've
asked i've seen on another podcast where
they've asked like why do you
not hate chinese people but if there was
to be a rivalry in asia who would it be
and they've always said chinese people
like different korean people and a
vietnamese girl as well
they are like oh out of all the asians
like if you if you were to say i dislike
this type of asian
they're like all of them said i don't
dislike any type of asian but if i was
to
gun to my head if i had to say someone
would be chinese people they all said it
and i think they said the reasons maybe
because they think they're that the best
type of asian
okay just how like jamaicans think
they're the best type of caribbean
yeah yeah yeah okay so like
obviously i don't really know like like
i don't really know that much caribbean
stuff
so i don't know on the islands if people
actually give a [ __ ] who's from jamaica
people yeah people in the caribbean are
too laid back to give a [ __ ] give any
of that
their men are zooting chilling swimming
smashing coconuts they're chilling they
don't give up
they don't give a [ __ ] and if anyone
else are who do you hate most in the
islands they're like
what are you on about big man i mean
like here
they didn't give a single [ __ ] i don't
care bro um
so yeah i don't know if there's that
kind of rivalry in the islands but yeah
that's
definite thing is it's like they
probably have resentments that like
if anyone like i just said like he's
korean but i just said
automatically to chinese yeah yeah when
you think of asia you think chinese
yeah and when you don't know someone
you'd either say they're asian or you
say they're chinese
if you were trying to like reference
someone to me you might be like
oh that that girl over there and i'd
even say to you oh the asian girl
or maybe just by reaction i'll be like
oh the chinese girl like i would never
say
korean vietnamese filipino like none of
that
um so that maybe that's why they have
resentments i don't know i would love to
please someone comment and tell me
please someone message me and tell me
especially if you're non if you're asian
but non-chinese if you're asian or not
chinese or even if you are chinese if
you hate any other type of asian tell me
if you're african you hate any other
type of african tell me and if you
happen to be from the islands
and for some reason you hate jamaicans
tell me and if you're jamaican you think
you're top done tell me
although i already think they think
they're talking but that's again like if
someone asked
me yeah they would never ask me are you
from trinidad
they would say are you jamaican yeah no
one never says like that's another thing
as well like people will ask
someone will say you're asian someone
will say you are african
no one will ever say oh that caribbean
guy they'll probably just say jamaican
or black
no one ever says oh he's like caribbean
like whatever they never say that
fair enough there's always if you're
calling someone
uh caribbean you're calling the jamaican
yeah in the typically on a day to day i
think also another
another aspect of like rivalry
is because of what that country like
produces and gives to the
either nation or population of people
for example
the nigeria garnetic i think because the
first initial rivalry started from
afrobeats in my opinion
okay because nigeria's always would
obviously always think
nigerian afrobeats is better than
ghanaian afrobeats yeah because
you listen not necessarily you but like
people listen to a lot more
nigerian afrobeats than any other
um race in africa in my opinion yeah
cause that's what you hear right in
clubs
as we hear on the radio yeah does do you
know what i mean yeah so that in itself
is a status point yeah then you
speak about the [ __ ] jollof rice okay
as almost every
almost every country makes their own
jello price in africa
um but it's always down to nigeria or
ghana as the top two or whatever but
i've only ever have eaten both i don't
really
it's rice's right it's been made wedding
party jollof rice is the best jollof
rice in the world yeah if you go to like
an african party
this is the best of i don't know it
could be a nigerian movement i made it
it could have been guiding women i don't
give a [ __ ]
can you taste it and be like that's a
good one um i i don't know
the thing is i don't know fair play i
just know it tastes nice yeah
whether it's i don't really give a [ __ ]
it's nice of course yeah um
so i think it depends on the the level
of what you can
produce from your country that then
determines the rivalry kind of thing so
i guess
so china as well china is a [ __ ] huge
country yeah
so that alone the populace alone is a
massive advantage
and chinese people are known to be
academically incredible they are do you
know what i mean they are
so and you you can obviously distinguish
between a japanese and a chinese person
so you never you never really you think
you can really bro i think i think you
can't really
know you can't one time yeah this is a
few years ago this is a few years ago
in one of my group chats yeah so it was
me aaron damon
um i think miles
and uh a guy called josh right so we
were all chatting chat and chat and chat
chat
and then josh said something
josh said something was chinese when it
was japanese and obviously you know all
of us men are heavy into animals
so don't disrespect japanese culture to
me yeah yeah so
he must have said oh such and such
chinese yeah and we were like that's
[ __ ] japanese bro
like get your [ __ ] straight yeah and we
were just going on and on and on about
the massive
difference between japanese and chinese
yeah and then so
he must have come up and said you might
need to shut up like
i guarantee you if i showed you a
chinese person a japanese person you
would never know the difference
and we were like big man put money on
the table i'm right
in you i [ __ ] know who's who yeah and
man was like bet
so he must have posted five pictures
right
five pictures i think they were all
girls five pictures i was like which
ones are japanese which one's chinese
yeah
so i was like easy chinese chinese
japanese chinese
japanese bang i put my numbers in
easy not sweaty easy my number's in
aaron chinese japanese japanese chinese
and i was thinking
and why is aaron's a bit off their mind
yeah anyway whatever
damon japanese japanese chinese chinese
japanese and i'm like
they're a bit different again miles
never replied so i don't think he
[ __ ] said anything yeah so we're all
there like
chat chat chat chat whatever whatever
whatever i know the difference i know
the difference yeah
man man give us the dot dot dot
they're all chinese
point proven you don't know the [ __ ]
difference to shut up
circle fam i've never been so like ah
i want to delete myself like
i wish i would just didn't care about
these man so i could have been like
james left a group
that's how i wanted to be i wanted the
next thing after he said that dot dot
dot
they're all chinese i want to be like
james the group chat
i was never been so embarrassed in my
life he i
it's the biggest circle i've ever
humbled by the way yeah yeah i had seven
slices of humble pie
i knew something was shady from when we
all said different things
because i thought my [ __ ] was the point
is so blatantly obvious which ones were
chinese and japanese and every man said
different things you still have the chat
or no
oh i mean i do but that i'm talking this
was maybe three four years ago yeah but
you still have the media oh you don't
put up no i just want to see you later
all right
i'll try i'll try i'll try um but yeah
that's
that's interesting um okay i really want
to try that now i feel like i
may be able to i don't know why i don't
know why
i don't know why i was in the same
position as you i'm not saying you can't
but i'm saying three of us tried
[Laughter]
and i was one million percent confident
oh wow
it's crazy that's a shame i said they're
all chinese
he must have been howling [ __ ]
howling like you absolute [ __ ] you
don't know
anything you watch tutu cartoon and you
think then you think you know about
japanese culture
you [ __ ] embarrassing
right it's a scenario yeah
so scenario right did you ever used to
watch power rangers as a kid
oh of course cool mike morphin
mitomorphin power rangers
be something something there was loads
of them yeah there's loads of them so
right yeah imagine this yeah so imagine
you get a dm tomorrow
yeah obviously you've got your job
you've got you had everything yeah
you get dm tomorrow like fujad
um my name's david i love the show i
love your look
i love your characteristics yeah
um we're doing a revamp characteristics
we're doing a revamp of the mighty
morphin power rangers yeah and i want
you
as the black ranger name your price
so you have to do two seasons oh my god
of mighty morphin power rangers
and he needs your social media phone
let's say in this scenario you got blue
tick
okay he needs your social media
following to promote the shower yeah
yeah
as you're going to be the new black
ranger yeah yeah yeah yeah
and you got to wear the the latex the
whole the hole the helmet
you got to take the helmet off you
you've got you have to do the whole
thing
yeah and you've like even when you're
fighting you know when they used to do
the little explosions
and then they dive yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah these aren't used to do rolly
pollies
all over and then they're jumping over
the cameras
you every time
you have to do all of that all of it
i'll run my phone
how much
two seats the two years as a black
ranger
latex everything you see your back you
see the moles on your body through these
things
they paper ep anyway i'd probably do it
for like a million up
and they're not going to pay you a
millionaire let's get rid of this that's
friends money
yeah they're not going to pay you a
million but i said i'll probably do it
for a millionaire
they're not gonna pay you a millionaire
let's get real this is your current
lifestyle
but i got a blue tick fam they need to
pay man yeah you've got blue tick
because of the pod
all right um you can get blues let's say
you've got a 10k blue tick you you're
still a baby you're not making money
money
okay i'd probably do it for
50k 50k in app 100k if they were willing
to pay me that yeah i'd do it
100 so you do it for 50. i do 50 i do
100 as well
again because obviously if i said you'd
do it for 100 if you're going to do it
but yeah go on obviously i'm trying to i
don't know where the gradient lies in it
cool let's say
okay let's yeah 50 well he says like
name your price let's say he says name
your price yeah i'm not going to tell
you what our budget is yeah but if
you're
if you're over yeah you're out okay but
if you're if you're if something that we
can afford yeah you're
in but i'm not going to haggle with you
name what you think you deserve
and that's it i'll say i'd say 50 to 100
bucks i don't know
50 let's go 50 to be humble 50. 50 bags
an ep
so what let's call it 10 apps a season
i'm sure there's more than that
call it 15 apps a season 30 amps
that's 300 bucks 300k no that's more no
i kind of do my mouse what 50 times what
how many hips 30 amps
over two years 50 times 150 bucks 150
no 1.5 mil what i was going to say 1.5
mil 1.5 million over two years
yeah 750 oh yeah oh yeah
cool but this is your identity now
you have to pose you can say they need
that bluetooth you need to be posting on
your story
to all your current things like yo
i'm tuning this one personal you're
personal
tune in this week guys
catch me [ __ ] up zordon
i'm [ __ ] doing it you know you're
doing the [ __ ] doing it i'm doing it
latex i'm doing it later i'm doing it
tall just on the side
i'm doing it 50 bags a nap i'm doing it
i don't give a [ __ ] what these guys
think about me
i'm doing it i'm doing it i don't even
know why i contemplated in the first
place
i'm doing it bro obviously the first
couple
and i'm assuming in this scenario i can
act i can do all these things it's my
assumption
yeah yeah yeah you do all right i
the only thing that would like
deter me would be like the first when
i'm doing like the first few episodes
because obviously i'm not really used to
this lifestyle so probably after like
episode five six
it's normal for me now this is this is
my job yeah give a [ __ ] yeah
the same way i was a bit anxious the
first time you started this podcast
that's true
and the first time you did a clip first
time people actually saw what the [ __ ]
were talking about yeah i was anxious
how did you feel the first time you had
to put it in your story or whatever i
don't remember
i don't remember but i know i felt
anxious i don't fully remember it was
it was obviously almost a year ago now
it was over a year ago i was
anxious anxious oh god that's funny
so yeah i think after after the first
few i wouldn't give a [ __ ]
fair play fair play honestly wouldn't
give i'm trying to think at what point
was i not anxious to put it in my story
anymore my personal story
i don't know probably last week
no i don't know but yeah i was
definitely anxious as well
there's been a few where i've when you
because of you send them to me and then
i put them on there's been a few
well i've listened to them feeling like
[ __ ] let's go for this
i think the period one oh period
because i got a lot of responses from
that did you i got a lot of responses
you got a lot of praise from it
you got a lot of praise from i was
perplexed obviously i put it up
regardless
but i was thinking a lot of people are
actually either going to pray it
and say something to themselves about
the situation or just skip
yeah but i got quite a bit of
acknowledgement i was thinking okay you
did it's not as bad as i thought fam
and after that i think after that one i
was fine i didn't i got the opposite
yeah these monocles i'll be a child
immature
and i'm like i don't wanna i don't wanna
[ __ ]
blood like am i i felt like i was in the
twilight zone
i remember i think i remember i remember
the video
and it's because i think
i brought up periods or saturn and
initially straight off the bat you're
like
yeah yeah yeah i think that was it that
one threw people off there was
that reminds me i remember when i put it
on tick tock yeah there were wars in the
comments
wars in the comments wars and then a
warm girl's like oh imagine having a
[ __ ] imagine having a boyfriend
that's [ __ ]
like can't even [ __ ] on period or
something like that and then a guy's
riding for me yeah one guy's defending
me yeah
and he's like what the [ __ ] and she's
like oh he's gagging at the thought of
period he's like now he's gagging at the
foot of [ __ ]
a girl on her [ __ ] period it's a huge
difference two different things and then
just going back and forth back and forth
these hoes were slaying me
he's a child not a real man can't even
do this and that and i'm like
i literally felt like i was in a
different universe yeah i felt like i
was in rick and morty or something i was
like
am i crazy i don't want to
rub my dick on blood i don't want to do
it
why am i getting so much heat i don't
know man it's probably because these
guys get horny on their period yeah they
get they get disgraced with the morning
that that veg or your horny slippery
slip
that consistencies are next thing their
joy or consistency
[Music]
that's when you know that's where you
know that's the good puss
when is veg oil consistency guys that's
a slippery slide you'll snap your neck
if you're going hold up jesus christ
snap your neck if you go down jesus
christ that's funny boy
oh my god you know i'm completely off
topic
you know [ __ ] like no win no fee claims
and stuff
no win no fee yeah like when you like
have an accident at work or whatever
how brave must you be to go back to work
afterwards
i've never thought about their mind
going back to work i just assumed they
take the money right you know what i
mean
yeah after you sued after you sued them
won the p and you just because you're
not going to leave let's be honest
um you probably need to work you need
the work you're going to get like 10 k
out of it
15k yeah you're not quitting your job
and then you go back to work
you must have balls you've got stones
stones you've got
balls stones cojones i couldn't lock my
boss in the face i feel like the only
person that could probably do that
with confidence is donald trump
what he can slip and fall at the white
house no no no no
not him in his current job him as a
human being oh because he just doesn't
give a single [ __ ] he doesn't
give a [ __ ] donald trump listen to
something the other day and someone was
slew in donald trump
and they were like tell a lie though
like
do you not think he would be so live to
just go to a strip club with
he'll be the if you remember and i
thought about it i was like if me and
donald trump went out
as boys yeah just on a night out like no
holds barred yeah
would have the sickest night he would he
would
do anything and get get away with
everything he would
he's the type of snot coke of a girl's
[ __ ] oh facts
he will live it up on a nice house
donald trump will do the thing
in a stripy he's going all out
i didn't imagine donald trump will have
a knight
me and donald trump wear the knight of
my life he's got balls bro
he's got the biggest ball like he's such
a have you seen him like tweet you don't
really you know
i'm more active on twitter and he just
tweets the most
outrageous stuff i don't ever get
offended by him anymore because i knew
he i know he's out of his mind
yeah but he's out of his mind i can't
get angry at
like someone who's maybe insane yeah
there's a maniac energy
when all the looting and stuff was
happening in america a man said when the
loot is up the shooting starts
you're a maniac this is your president
of the country
my man looks at himself and he must just
think like
even you don't hear nothing he just like
the man's looking at right cool where
the looting shots they shoot himself
closes his mouth and just spins his
chair just spins in his
oval office his toupee's waving and he's
like
[ __ ] i'm sick [ __ ] i'm sick he must get
head
off the bat straight from then i'm
[ __ ]
sick when the looting starts big man the
shooting starts come in a little bit
cool fam donald trump is the funniest
kid
he is he's literally a child he and it
baffles me because obviously
durian obama's tenure
he was saying how he would do a better
job than him and blah blah blah
i'm thinking the your country's right
now is literally in
ruins yeah literally in ruins i hear you
um apparently though i don't know how
true this is
hearing from like american people
not even people that are like pro-trump
and stuff yeah apparently pre-covered
the economy was in better shape
with trump as the president then it
wasn't with obama okay purely because he
only cares about business
yeah so economy as in how businesses are
going yeah yeah so he just
feeds business people yeah like anything
business people want
he gets them yeah so that's why probably
why the economy was in a good
stead but in terms of like humanity yeah
he he's not human
he doesn't care he's not human he
doesn't care he's got hoes
he must have him and epstein were they
were close
they were close him and epstein was that
close
she was um when she got locked man said
i wish her well or something like that
he slipped up they said like oh what do
you have to say about like elaine
getting arrested and someone said i wish
her i wish her the best or
i hope she's well or some [ __ ] like that
and they were like
are you sure she's a paedophile
she grooms children for her husband or a
boyfriend to [ __ ]
he's like yeah i wish that [ __ ] well
him and glenn go back they go back
she used to pat news for him all the
time on
[ __ ] island or whatever for him
gillette was patterning little girls for
trump from early
and [ __ ] prince andrew prince
prince andrew is
i was gonna say he's a g he's not a g
but he's just how has he gotten away
with everything like
no one's talking about it i swear he
denied
being in a pho or something yeah he
denied the phone and he's when they say
before he said he doesn't remember it
he said he just doesn't remember i'm not
an excuse that's not an excuse
from these men like trump and the royal
family they don't see danger the way we
see
yeah yeah yeah there's about if if i got
patented
if i got caught on that kind of lie yeah
like oh shiva
oh shiva man didn't even have to agree
to do the interview yeah they must say
we want to interview about this epstein
thing yeah
knowing he's involved man still said all
right and then they said like
one like you on sex island you're boys
of epstein mazza i'm not boys of him i
don't know him
he's like this is a photo of you and him
pally pally
is like with a young thing with a you
like
one this is you emma's like i don't
remember that
he's like so were you boys of him or not
no i don't know him
explain the photo i don't remember that
photo
like you can't you're implicated son
you're in it man's like i'm a prince
i'm not in any do you know what's mad
obviously you know how the daily mail
hey um prince harry and megan
meghan markle oh yeah um so
someone i think daily mail or whatever
one of them shitty newspapers
um tweeted something to do with
the size of their yard like saying it's
a piss stick out they've got three
bathrooms or two something stupid
something
very very very unimportant someone said
it's a piss take that prince harry and
his mrs have a three-bedroom
bathroom or something stupid like that
daily mail tweeted that okay it was
something stupid like that yeah and then
someone quote tweeted how can you be
talking about this when prince andrew is
[ __ ] children
do you know what i mean like this
it i don't know i don't know i don't
know i don't know
the world we live in some people just
get away with [ __ ] and he rolls around
in a top hat
not giving not giving a [ __ ] he's like
willy wonka
prince andrew is willy wonka he just
twiddles his cane with his top pet and
lives in la la land
bro he just [ __ ] kids and just rolls
he doesn't care it's crazy man bro these
men live in a
bubble in a parallel universe in a
bubble
a parallel universe it doesn't make
sense
oh i need to i need to know how this
epson thing unfolds i know but
obviously he's dead and elaine's still
in jail yeah some people think galain's
gonna [ __ ] um
right right right on trump and stuff
it's never going to happen because she
would die apparently there's a piss
video of trump as well in it
i don't know there's a video where he's
pissing on someone no people are just
waiting for it to drop
pre-election know the funny thing
i feel like he might still get reelected
in november you know
fam that's because their boy biden has
dementia
do you know this no i don't
he doesn't know where he is half the
time
biden doesn't know where he is half the
time he's does like
uh interviews and like these these meet
up speeches and stuff like that
all the time and he'll just start
speaking and just not know where he is
and just be like cool apparently he's
had like three brain surgeries or two
brain surgeries jesus
and like he's just not a stable person
oh wow and like um
so people think trump might get this
competitor that's the closest company
the way they pattern it in america
doesn't make sense
they've got two options even trump who's
a pedophile maniac
who just tweets what he wants when he
wants and then gets a [ __ ]
and then you've got biden who's lost his
mind
he's like he's in his 70s i'm sure trump
is in his 70s as well yeah
like how they got like the most powerful
country in the world
is a toss-up between two demented mad
men who are old as [ __ ]
and it's like they don't one of them
doesn't know what's going on and the
other one definitely doesn't know what's
going
on
you know i was just thinking about that
sorry it's got you off you know i was
thinking about that imagine being
trump's wife
like she obviously she
knows him and known off him for years
and years and years and years like
they've been married they've got kids
together and everything
but she doesn't get implicated anything
obviously because she's the first lady
and that's what i've never even called
her the first i don't think people
address her as the first lady she's not
first lady
she's exactly she's not michelle she's
known michelle
i've only ever called a first lady
michelle i've only ever called someone
the first lady and that person was
michelle yeah
she's known michelle i've never actually
called her the first time she's a yeah
she's not the first lady she's a yeah
that's marriage to the bridge she's just
a yeah in the office
she's a yet that lives in the white
house she's not the [ __ ] first lady
but she must get she must get a lot of
stick as well and the kids i don't think
she gives a [ __ ] either she doesn't love
her
yeah of course i think that's the reason
why she doesn't give a [ __ ] because she
doesn't love him
yeah their whole family is useless the
whole family is useless
trump is crazy crazy you found you stand
up against him i'll get you sacked
i've watched a um i watched the
documentary not too long ago i think it
was about maybe a month half ago two
months ago about
um mob crime in new york
um obviously trump tower is in new york
i believe okay
since i was in york yeah um so they had
like five i can't remember whether
the thing is called but it was by the
same um
producer that did don't [ __ ] with cuts
oh it's called uh fear city
that was the one yeah i watched like the
first episode that's the one
so they there was a there was a thing
where obviously these
five crime bosses ran new york city
ran you'll see and then they spread out
to different um states in america
and one of the industries that they
had power over was the um building
industry like
building actual buildings construction
construction yeah yeah yeah yeah
construction industry
yeah and one of the constructions they
showed was the truck tower which is
weird so it was just
obvious because you're talking about
trump before and it's just crazy how
they put that in there so it's
implicating that he
obviously must have known that these mob
guys are the ones that were [ __ ]
everything up and you know what i mean
speaking of that yeah did you know trump
he's he's like a prince andrew
he just denies oh yeah he denies
he denies have you seen him in press
conferences when
uh a news reporter asks him something
like controversial
and he's like i don't want to answer
that and he moves on to the next person
yeah he doesn't care he doesn't care
he doesn't care i need as much as i
don't rate him i need to be more like
him
it just doesn't give a single [ __ ] he's
a stand-up comedian he doesn't does it
and that's why i said he's the only one
that can do a no-win no fee
and then come back to work the next day
rags it just like it never happened
never happened he doesn't care he would
you see him
now i see it you see he would roll up he
will slip and fall in sainsbury's
movie twister he'll take them for
everything they've got and he'll roll in
the next day backwards apron on and just
check just fam straight face
straight face trump doesn't give a [ __ ]
he doesn't care about anyone by himself
he'll throw anyone to the wolves he
doesn't care
he doesn't care about you um but what's
he call it
jesus um apparently he's he's um
he is like been sued okay so many times
by like
for construction because he makes his
money and probably development i'm sure
okay that's where the most of his money
is from okay what he would do
is for all of his construction when he
was younger yeah he would hire
he would apparently loads of buildings
that he's um
developed in new york and stuff like
that he's got done for free
oh because he will only hire very small
contractors
very small contractors who are just up
and coming so like oh i need a
bricklayer
he'll hire a very small bricklayer and
like i want to hire you for this massive
project and obviously the bricklayer is
like obviously oh my [ __ ] god yeah
he's like i'm gonna pay you
a mill and he's like oh my god yeah yeah
dude like i'm gonna do it like
i get as many men as you can this is how
much money you're gonna make
um to do it's gonna be six months worth
of work can you handle it
like cool same for the [ __ ]
scaffolders
small company same for the electricians
small company
all these mana gassed yeah yeah gas yeah
and then when pay time comes
the black cool we've done all the work
yeah trump tower was built yeah
like you're over six mil like thank you
so much for the opportunity
man's like cool safe i'm not gonna pay
you
and they're like what do you mean i'm
like i'm not gonna pay you and they're
we're like alright save
i will sue you and he's like go on then
and then they sue him and he will
bury them in legal fees so they can't do
anything
he uses his power because it's cheaper
for him to go through the legal process
and bury them
to bankrupt them through the legal it's
cheaper for him to bankrupt them through
the legal process than it is just to pay
them the money that
he's that he owes them because he's got
so much money that he knows they can't
beat him in court
so he would just put a delay on this and
there's something on this or
get his lawyers to do all their lawyer
[ __ ] where it's going to cost them
so much money to get him into court to
pay up
that they just can't afford it so they
just leave it
and these towers built for free
i never knew that i only found my
brother told me that i only found that
outlet last week
that's how you know this guy has balls
bruv
balls of steel slipping full balls
he's got balls doesn't give a [ __ ] about
anyone
he doesn't give a [ __ ] about anyone this
is a president
and then same thing where people have
approached him and said like what do you
have to say about
these legal all this stuff allegations
allegations even back in the 80s when it
was happening
people would ask him he's exactly the
same then as he is now people ask him
like one for all these people that are
suing you he's like no i'm suing me he's
like
yes they are this is greg
he's suing you he works for a
scaffolding company he
he's suing you currently and he's like
i've never seen this guy before no one's
suing me
what's an awesome he would win every
american
he will be on camera like no one's suing
me and then he'll spud greg like i'll
see you in court
he will just lie and he doesn't blink
he's just not fazed
he lives in la la land parallel universe
parallel
universe ah what a guy
i have to rate him the balls you have to
rate the balls you have to
he's got the biggest balls it's
different
what a way to think about someone wrong
a very controversial man the most
controversial man going on this planet
he says what he wants to say and does
what he wants to do just gets away with
it fam gets away with it he gets
investigated by the fbi and says you're
sacked speaking of the fbi do you
remember when
obviously when this whole um epson thing
came out
and then i think they wanted to there
was a judge
that was going to look into it and then
the judge's yard got ran up into by a
delivery driver
and shut up the kid and the husband the
judge was a woman
shot like i think killed the kid and
shot the husband and husband survived
never heard of this in my life and he
rolled up as a as like a
like an amazon amazon delivery driver
but was a [ __ ] assassin
and that went on for like two weeks and
then i've not heard a thing about it
since
what yeah he's a mobster
thumb trump is a mobster he will get
away with any
fam and he'll just eat his scrambled
eggs in the morning like same way
same way he he's like a dumber version
of um kevin spacey when
in um what was the show house of cards
house of cards he's like a
crazier dumber version yeah yeah yeah
yeah from him came in space he didn't
give a [ __ ] in that show
he pushed man on a train track the yeah
the yell on the train right he's having
an affair
yeah and then she said i'm gonna take
you down man just pushed you in front of
a train
and got on with his day i'm done with
you and got on with his day
he's trump wow kevin spacey in house of
cards is donald trump
push the yard in front of the train and
just carried on with his day and he
[ __ ]
he's a pedophile as well doesn't that's
what you showed about cancer now well he
came off the show
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah something to do
with kids i don't know how much of that
was substantiated
no i don't think it wants to do a kid it
not no he
well i say kids i think it was a 17 year
old guy
who was working he was like an intern
okay a set or something i think he
grabbed his dick or asked him to grab
his dick or something like it wasn't
as i'm gonna this is me saying oh it
wasn't even that bad but like it was
like i don't think anything i don't
think he's
actually been convicted of anything
okay i could be completely wrong i don't
know that's how i'm sure he's not
actually being convicted of anything
okay but i think the
only young thing was was my man
um touching up or asking
a kid to tell you she needed to help her
fam it's just not doing
diego
he something that you asked the kid to
touch his dick or he touched the kids
like a 17 year old's dick or something
like that there was another one where he
got accused from a guy
he he touched a guy's dick uh in a club
and the club the guy from the club tried
to sue him
take him to court and then they went
through the guys text messages
and then the guy was texting his
girlfriend the whole night like right
i'm getting moved to by kevin spacey
like basically let's see how far we can
take it so he was down
he was down just to see how far it would
go and then kevin said
ref roll come back to the telly let's go
i want to [ __ ] and the guy was like cool
cool cool
and then eventually obviously as when
push comes to shelf he was like
i'm out then he tries to say like oh
kevin spacey was harassing me in a club
grabbing my dick all this stuff and
obviously there's
security camera footage so it was enough
for them to like bring kevin spacey to
court like big man
work one for these allegations kevin
spacey's like he was down
he was down oh [ __ ] and if they didn't
find those text messages then obviously
he probably would have got charged
these people want p that's the thing for
every people say there's no smoke
without fire
but a lot of the time for every all
these cases there's always an extra case
that was absolute [ __ ] like people
at the same time
bs people are predators and people are
animals but also people are also
money hungry [ __ ] like that bungalow
two things you spoke about the episode
yeah
yeah yeah it was a very so that's why
criminal very socially accurate
show very with the times it's very good
i need to watch it it's very very good
um but yeah do you want to do ahmadista
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry for the audio
this is
that slid out my hand for the audio
listeners james picked up his phone to
do about the [ __ ]
he threw it on my dick it slipped out
like soap it slipped out my hand like so
oh my god i'm so sorry [ __ ] awesome
sorry bro
um cool
gangnam
i've got this one ready
oh god i know
ah gang yeah right so
so am i the [ __ ] hi lads hopefully
you see this
love the pod makes my day go a lot
quicker so keep it up etc
thank you very much doug um so
i was with my ex for over two years we
lived together and everything was
blessed to start with she then lost her
job
and fell out with her family and as a
result got mental health problems
anxiety depression and suicidal thoughts
i did all i could to help her taking
days off work
to take her to therapy etc anyway it all
got too much for me
at the start of the year as i was
getting constant abuse from her
physically and verbally
since the breakup her mental health has
gotten even worse and on a few occasions
she's tried to end her life
jesus this is dark all of her family and
friends blame me for this
and come round to where i live to let
these feelings be known
anyway i want to know am i the [ __ ]
for breaking up with her
as she was mentally ill and am i to
blame for any attempts on her life
as every day i get told that i am also
i'm from northampton
and i can confirm that we do call it
north
gang thank you god
last point [ __ ] um back to the
original point [ __ ]
what was the what was the title am i the
answer for was it i found one
it's a fun one are you yeah so it is
nice there's no titles
[ __ ] so is he the [ __ ] for breaking
up with his girlfriend
because she was really struggling with
her mental health and it was too much
for him
yes and no i want to say no
i want to say yes actually because
he would have not prior to them being a
relationship
he would have known she had or has
mental
she goes through mental issues would he
i believe so
in this he didn't make out that he knew
he in his
from he could be lying but from his
depiction
it all started when she lost her job
this all started when she lost her job
that's when it all started
as far as he's saying he could be wrong
but as far as we know okay he's saying i
had no idea until she got sacked from
her job and then all of this started
okay um taking that into consideration
it's a obviously i in my opinion it's a
much more deeper
rooted issue than her just losing her
job 100
um
but then again there's no time frame
like did he stay with her one week and
then dip
do you stay with her one month and then
dip yeah we don't have much time no but
ah it's hella tough because it's like a
very tough moment yeah like
even the thing is as well even when
there's time frames it's like
he's one thing worse than the other yeah
because like
some would say he would be better off
getting out there earlier
rather than sticking by her for i don't
know like you said a month six months a
year yeah
and then deciding this is too much for
me yeah like i don't know it's tough
because
like you said there the the mental
health is clearly a more deep rude issue
than her just losing yeah then her just
losing her job but at the same time
i'm not saying this doesn't make you an
[ __ ] but being an [ __ ] doesn't
also make necessarily make you a bad
person
yeah like sometimes people look out for
themselves
yeah and that might people can call that
selfish and all that stuff but at the
end of the day as well
you've only got one life to live yeah
yeah yeah he's not here
to be her carer he's not here to be her
supporter he doesn't know if he wants to
marry this girl
yeah like this isn't someone necessarily
that he's decided to spend the life best
of his life his life
this is just his current girlfriend yeah
that he's now
finding out that wow that she's got
deep-rooted issues yeah and she has
suicidal thoughts and as well on top of
that he said that she was physically
abusive
to herself to him to him she was
verbally and physically abusive no i'm
dipping
verbal i can probably take because i can
give it back yeah
yeah i mean yeah physical yeah don't put
your hands on me cuz i'm out
fam i'm out i'm out i'm out
all right i'm out here it's yeah i'm out
you're not putting paws on me i don't
care what you want to do to yourself
you're not putting your hands on me i'm
out like and it's not even that um
there's no disrespect to like people
that are suffering with mental health
issues and stuff and i know people
do go for mental health stuff and may or
may not have suicidal thoughts but
when you it's like the vegan thing
if you're vegan i don't mind you being
vegan yes they're two completely
different contrasts yes of course yeah i
don't mind you being vegan
but don't bring that onto my life don't
try to force me to yeah
i mean because you chose your life i'm
not saying obviously people don't choose
mental health
you get that yeah yeah or being mentally
not being mentally healthy
rather i know people don't choose that
and i know people don't choose suicidal
thoughts
but within the same breath
if you if i am as your boyfriend
trying to help you and you put hands on
me
it's sticky man it is it's sticky have
you ever seen the film
5050 with joseph gordon-levitt yes
yes i've seen it once but i know it's a
great i think i've seen it once or twice
i know it's a great idea
i know it's a good movie i have not seen
it for years i'd never cry for movies
that maybe could be close
yeah that's such a good movie um but
there's a part in there where obviously
he's dating a girl yeah at the time that
he know finds out he's got cancer yeah
yeah
and he comes to her and says like
obviously when they decided like
it's pretty much inoperable um ninety
percent of people die from it or well no
he's like 50 50 chance
of survival um he has to go for all this
chemo stuff like that from
early from day one he sits sit down and
says i'm giving you an
out yeah a guilt free out if you don't
want to do this
or if you're not ready for this you need
to say now yeah guilt-free i won't hold
anything against you because you did not
sign up for this yeah like if you want
to go
you need to go now yeah and she's like
i'm not going anywhere
and then she starts [ __ ] cheating on
him later down the road i forgot
and she blames it all on the stress of
the chemo
and all of this stuff and she starts
being late for picking up from his
appointments and she starts not sticking
around
and she you know he finds out that she's
been cheating on him and all this stuff
and he says that i gave you a [ __ ]
out
like i gave you the opportunity it
sounds like he was never given the
opportunity for that out
it sounds like
all of this happened i don't have the
full account but i can only go from what
we've been told
yeah and from what we've been told he
was never given the opportunity
to be like for her to be like listen
this is tough for me yeah like i i know
you you obviously we've had a great race
up until this point and we're in a good
place but like
i'm seriously struggling yeah and if i'm
gonna need a lot of support from you
and if this isn't what you're here for
yeah then you need to tell me now
because shit's about to get dark yeah
and i'm having suicidal at the point
where she lost her job yeah
she's lost the job she starts thinking
about killing herself like it's up to
you
obviously you're struggling stuff with
that it's up to you to at least be a
little bit socially aware and just be
like listen
shit's about to get really rough and i'm
gonna need someone
yeah yeah you can be that someone or you
can [ __ ] off yeah
and the choice is yours it doesn't sound
like he was given that option
then again most people just like the
[ __ ] from 5050
aren't cutthroat enough to say to say
i'm out yeah most people like
donald trump is donald trump's literally
the only one
who would be like bro thanks for telling
me because i was gonna go anyway
i was gonna dip regardless you didn't
sit me down i would have done it first
suicidal thoughts out i'm gone i'm sorry
i'm not here for this
i want a [ __ ] and laughs [ __ ] and
laughs and
dinners you can't even afford dinners
so i'm gone but thank you for giving me
the guilt-free option
it's a win-win good luck ah
an [ __ ] yeah obviously my man stuck
around for however long he did and then
he got abused
and then he said i'm done with this i'm
done with this
and like like i said bare people would
be like you're an [ __ ] whatever
but for me i kind of have to say you're
an [ __ ]
but i don't know if i mean it or not do
you know what you mean that's why i said
yes or no at the beginning yeah
i have to say you're an [ __ ] but in
the day you have to look out for
yourself you do have to as well because
i'm not kidding you're not putting hands
on me it's tough man you know i'm not
going to sit in a relationship with
people putting paws on me because they'd
like to say this is not what i signed up
for yeah
we were happy yeah and obviously yes you
have men who have issues and all this
stuff and this is like that's horrible
and i'm i'm sorry and it sucks but it's
just like yo
you're not going to put hands on me and
get away with it i don't care
i will leave you go away i will leave
you i want to live my life i want to be
happy
but yeah the fact that her family's
coming up in his yard
at blaming him for her trying to kill
herself
sort your household out sort that
surname
in your family sort your household out
now get off my doorstep
get the [ __ ] off my doorstep before
hoses start flying
i'll splash water on you get out oh my
dad
get out you're not coming by my
residence talking [ __ ] about it's my
fault this [ __ ] tried to kill herself
get out i'm not living life oh [ __ ] but
yeah man
um i don't know what to tell you bro yes
i said yes or no
yes i know it's a 50 50. it's a 50 50
thing yeah man like
you kind of are but you're kind of not
so sorry g
i'm sorry i had to go through that bro
peak but yeah
wrap wrap see you next week